platforms like venmo or zell make it
easy to send money paying your friends
back for dinner receiving payments in
your side hustle all of that so of
course the irs is now stepping in to
take a closer look starting this year
users with accounts taking in more than
600 in payments will begin receiving tax
forms so what does that mean for you
well you have to pay taxes on that money
coming in
garrett watson is a senior policy
analyst at the tax foundation where he's
an expert in federal and state tax
policy gary welcome to quick take
there's a lot of misconceptions out
there so clear some of them up for us
the irs does not care about my friend
paying me back for her share of the
hotel room we got last weekend but it
does care if another friend is paying me
for an apartment that i rent out on
airbnb right
that's right i mean the bottom line here
with these reporting changes is it's
changing what information the irs has
but it doesn't change your tax situation
so if you are engaging in transactions
on venmo or elsewhere like on paypal
you're paying someone back and it's not
a taxable transaction you have nothing
to worry about if you're running a
business where there's income that might
be taxed this is another place for you
to see where that information is being
reported another place for the irs to
see it and in that situation you want to
make sure you're paying your taxes
properly okay you mentioned taxable
transaction what does that really mean
though i mean how will the platform how
will venmo or zell be able to tell
what's a taxable transaction what's not
so what platforms like venmo and sale
are doing is they're just reporting all
of the gross transactions that are
happening on their platform that could
be if you're running a business and that
income could be taxed or it could be
something as simple as paying back a
friend for dinner
but what you have to know is that this
is just changing what information is
being reported to the irs and it's
really up to you when you're reporting
on your tax forms to determine whether
or not that income is subject to tax so
in the case of being a small business so
you're collecting uh your revenue
through paypal or through venmo you may
want to take that that income and ensure
that you are properly deducting expenses
and that you're paying taxes on that net
income but if you're in a situation
where you're paying back a friend or
using it to to give a gift to someone
you don't have to worry about that
amount being reported on a form it's not
considered taxable income so you don't
have to report it on your tax forms got
it but nevertheless uh the platforms
will send the the report anyway to the
irs and whether you follow up is
basically your call based on whether you
run a business or not and are making
income off of those transactions can't
businesses just change their accounts to
individual accounts and call their
vendors and customers friends and family
yeah there definitely is still going to
be opportunities for folks who are not
interested in complying with tax law to
try to get underneath this limit of 600
in order to or to mischaracterize the
nature of these transactions uh but the
the point of this change in the rule
which happened at beginning this year is
to provide the irs more information to
identify places where folks could be
doing that mischaracterizing their
transactions
and so that's just more reason to be
complying with tax law and following the
best practices when running a business
but if you're in a situation where you
are already paying taxes on your income
and doing things above board this this
reporting change is not not anything to
be worried about so the threshold for uh
everyone to watch out here is six
hundred dollars and that's total
transactions over one year so it's not
like you can break up six hundred
dollars into ten transactions of 60 each
the limit used to be 20 000 over 200
transactions
why did it change to such a small amount
what we found originally was because
that transaction threshold before was
really high 200 transactions or 20 000
a lot of folks who might be engaging in
side hustles or in more informal
activity using these platforms weren't
getting any uh any forms from the irs uh
and the irs wasn't getting that
information themselves and so that led
to both confusion potentially for folks
who didn't know potentially how much
income they earned on those platforms
and it did not create transparency for
the irs who may not have known whether
or not these transactions were occurring
and so when they lower this threshold to
600 a much larger group of folks
including folks who really don't owe any
taxes on some of these transactions are
are captured in this reporting and i
think that's what's generating a lot of
this
misinformation that's out there about
whether or not particular transactions
are taxed really important to highlight
that this is not a change in tax law
it's just a change in what's being
reported okay i i see what you're
getting at nevertheless people on social
media are just outraged that small
business owners are getting taxed um or
at least being scrutinized when you've
got big businesses getting to keep the
tax cuts that was pushed through by the
trump administration and ironically this
new lower limit of 600 is part of the
american rescue plan that was passed by
the white house the biden administration
last year is that correct
that's right and it's much part of a
much larger discussion about what is the
best use of for this information on the
irs as well as the broader discussion
about
resourcing for the irs and compliance as
you highlight there's been a lot of
discussion about trying to ensure
there's higher compliance for higher
earners and for corporations uh but this
change really is gonna get at folks who
are uh participating in in the gig
economy who are earning between six
hundred dollars and twenty thousand
dollars uh though it's worth mentioning
that this can have some benefit for
those folks in that they may also
receive this form from the irs so that
will give them some more transparency on
what they could potentially be owing or
what's being reported to the irs as a
transaction
also it gives them a fresh way to look
at perhaps where they will might be able
to take deductions on some of their
business expenses and reduce their
taxable income the irs is not in great
shape i mean they don't they don't have
enough funding they don't have enough
resources how likely is it that small
business owners would be audited if they
decided to ignore this tax form that
gets sent from venmo so the likelihood
of being audited overall especially if
you're not a very high earner is remains
pretty low and it still remains low even
after this reporting change because the
irs has seen their audit rates go down
over the last 10 years
and so if you are in a situation where
you're receiving this form say for
personal reasons and you're worried
about being audited on that uh it's
probably not a high risk not something
to worry about if you are worried and
you want to mitigate any potential risk
having information on hand on the nature
of those transactions is always really
helpful a really good example of that is
for example if you're taking a rent
payment on behalf of a roommate and
relaying it to your landlord that could
add up to you know north of ten thousand
dollars a year uh but that's pretty
straightforward situation where you can
keep those records uh if you're a small
business owner of course i think it just
underscores the importance of just just
maintaining the best practices of your
business right separating out your
business and personal accounts keeping
receipts if you're making deductions
those are things you should already be
doing but this reporting change just
makes that more important because it
might highlight some of these potential
issue areas if you're not doing that to
the irs okay so keep good records is
your advice here so i have to admit
garrett when i first saw this news my
first thought was drug dealers are all
going to move back to cash or crypto i
mean they're going to run away from
these different platforms
yeah i think there is going to be as a
trade-off to this some incentive for
folks who are not
above board on their transactions to
move away from these platforms and that
is going to be
one thing that the irs and treasury will
have to have to monitor if there are
other
ways to try to get at those types of
transactions there's already of course
monitoring in the financial system for
illicit activity and there might be a
bit more of that as a trade-off of
trying to be a bit more transparent with
these digital platforms uh and so that
will have to be part of and that really
shows that this is a holistic discussion
right you can try to plug one hole in uh
reporting in the tax system but that
will create behaviors that show up
elsewhere uh in crypto and elsewhere in
the financial system so that is an
important consideration as policymakers
think of next steps on reporting yeah
absolutely everyone in fintech likes to
talk about how the future is cashless
cash will soon become obsolete we're all
going to be like sweden but its policy
changes like the one that we're dealing
with right now that will keep cash
really more popular than ever the
thinking is that cash transactions are
non-taxable and are and therefore or i
should say that they're not traceable
and therefore not taxable how would you
respond to that
right so in the tax system generally
speaking the nature of how you pay a
transaction or
try to work with folks financially it
has no bearing on whether or not a
transaction is taxable so if you're
taking a cash for a particular uh for
revenue somewhere that income may still
be just as taxable as if you took it
digitally and while it's true that cash
can have some looking some challenges
for folks to trace that if it does have
any interaction in the financial system
if you put that cash into a into a
checking account or withdraw it
elsewhere there will be records that tie
that cash to you so unless you're you're
in an operation that's fairly
sophisticated there's still going to be
a lot of risk in in doing it that way uh
best practice is to remain above board
and report the cash stuff that you are
getting via tips or other forms of
revenue
garrett great stuff thank you so much
really appreciate it garrett watson
joining us from the tax foundation a lot
to think about come tax filing season of
course it does not apply for 2021 taxes
it only applies to 2022 taxes so this is
something we'll be dealing with in april
of 2023
this is bloomer quick take i'm scarlet
faux